the number one thing men crave from women
men want to feel appreciated
he's serving you
whether that's driving you around so you can be the passenger princess
or taking you out on dates
simply being there to make you feel safe
provided for
and protected
that's him serving you
things he does for you is serving you
the number one thing you can do to fuel his desire to continue to serve you
is giving him gratitude.
The  more appreciation,
and gratitude you have for a man
the more he wants to serve you,
which in return serves them truly
it's so simple to just acknowledge what they do for you and appreciate them!
to say, “I acknowledge what you've done for us,
thank you” yes,
you're in this together
but simply saying or giving appreciation really does go a long way for them
you can say I know you've been at work all day and you're exhausted
but I really appreciate what you're doing for us and our family
Say I really appreciate it
say thank you
this will make the biggest difference
to make someone feel seen
Because we all have the desire to feel seen or heard for who we really are